[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
savezvu que dans l'expérience de
l'environnement on utilise tous nos sens
et que 75 % des images de ces
expériences sont réalisé avec
l'observation alors je vais vous
demander de mettre vos Têt et vos sens
en blanc en neutre et simplement
regarder défiler les
images
notre conception de la ville et de la
campagne est construit par l'ensemble
d'image lors de nos expériences
quotidiennes elles vont déterminer notre
zone de confort c'est-à-dire
l'environnement dans lequel on se sent
plus confortable dans lequel on se sent
plus famil on sent plus familial et que
on va
identifier qui va nous aider à
identifier notre
identité voici ma représentation de
ville Mexico est l'image de l'urbain de
la danse population d'une métropole et
aussi euh d'une ville plein en culture
toujours insoleillé et vivant en
24/24 depuis ce temps j'ai décidé
d'aller voir autrement
je me suis installée au Québec un
endroit où j'ai sortis de tout confort
et de mon milieu identitaire et oui vous
allez me dire que ma ville et les viille
Kbis sont très différents mais c'est
parfois dans les oppositions qu'on
trouve des réponses et dans mon cas
c'était cette différence de milieux qui
m'a fait réaliser l'importance de bien
comprendre les milieux d'intervention
avant d'agir à Norte quelle échelle
celle de l'habitat celle de la
rue celle du quartier et celle de la
ville et aussi celle du
territoire chaque geste spécifique doit
être pensé globalement avant
d'agir localement et ça c'est c'est vrai
dans les petites villes que dans les
grands villes encore plus pertinent
parfois dans les petites villes comme
Sainte-Marie qui on a l'intention de
continuer à croître parce que c'est
encore le temps de prendre des bonnes
décisions tirer des expériences de plus
et àu je vous invite aujourd'hui à
oser voir autrement à oser autrement nos
villes je vous emmène dans mon monde par
à travers mes découvertes et mes
croyances pour bâtir plus
humaines aujourd'hui avec l'information
qui est toujours apportée dé mè et on
pense on pense que on peut toujours
sauter au résultat sans trop y réfléchir
on veut des réponses et des résultat à
l'instant ça et même parfois
pourriè la réalité c'est que not mode de
vie change sensé c'est plus vite que
jamais notre volonté d'avoir une qualité
de vie est toujours là mais la course à
la consommation va augmenter davantage
la quantité d'avoir que la qualité de
vie je vous propose aujourd'hui de
prendre du recul à instant et se
demander pour qui sont construits nos
villes nos quartiers et nos bâtiments
pour
l'in l'action d'habité commence par la
compréhension des comportements et des
besoins humains et pour C dernière
l'expérience de l'environnement bâti et
des espaces publics c'est
déterminante alors il faudra mettre en
premier plan l'humain l'individu qui
perçoit son environnement et qui
interagit avec les
autres puis se demander quels sont les
besoins de ceux qui don VI à la ville de
l'enfant de l'ado de l'ÉIS de
l'adulte on a tous des besoins primaires
qui sont d'avoir un toit
être en
sécurité faire partie d'une communauté
et mieux se réaliser et c'est pour ça
que quand arrive le moment de magasiner
notre maison c'est un un choix très
difficile mais qui va nous nous donner
un grand sentiment de liberté en réalité
une liberté une fausse liberté parce que
l'avantail du choix des logements se
limite euh la hab les habitations qui
offrent le marché entre la maison de nos
rêves et celle qui on est capable de s
payer on pe souvent de vu l'élément
essentiel nos besoins réels
quellehitation sera capable de de nous
offrir la qualité de vie que l'on
souhaite existe-elle sur le
marché et aussi la recherche immobilière
nous nous va faire
penser à considérer la maison elle-même
mais pensz il faut penser aussi dans
quelle ville et dans quel quartier on
vous situé celle qui va être proche de
l'école des enfants du travail de
l'épicerie bref on a touses C activités
qui font partie de nos habitudes et
idéalement notre maison devra se trouver
où ces activités
sont puis quand on analyse les processus
traditionnels de développement on
réalise que c'est un une des des
problèmes on commence par construire nos
bâtimens des espaces résiduels on fait
nos espaces publics et à la fin on vut
que la vie s'adapte au milieu
construit il faudrait inverser les
processus commencer en m en premier plan
l'humain et se demander quelles sont les
activités et les ambiances qui on vu
avoir après planifier les espaces
publics et à la fin construire nos
bâtiments qui vont servir pour encadrer
ces espaces public dans une vision
d'ensemble lorsqu'on cherche une
habitation c'est la même chose c'est
d'abord une quartier et la qualité de
vie qu'ilofre qu'il s'agit de
choisir alors je vais vous présenter six
caractéristiques dont on ne peut pas
passer à côté si on veut vraiment
construire des milieux de vie de qualité
il faut d'abord que ça soit un milieu à
l'échelle humaine mais ça vous dit quoi
à l'échelle humaine
certains même pas un milieu où on se
sent un minuscule insecte au milieu de
nul partart qui vare écraser par les
voiture ce n'est pas non plus une rue où
les maisons sont tellement éloignées
d'une part et de l'autre que on se sent
dans un N
lande mais plutôt des rues construites à
l'Amon des gens des rues encadrées par
les bâtiments et par les arbres un
espace dans lequel on se sent bien quand
on marche et aussi quand on
conduit par exemple les cours avant trop
grand et engazonné vont disparaître
l'échelle humaine alors la cour avant
devrait être suffisamment grand pour
être appropriable mais suffisamment
petite pour avoir un aménagement des
qualités
elle cré un son de transition entre la
rue et les bâtiments dont elle protège
notre intimité
on pourrait envisager des rues étroites
comme celles que nous avons tous dans
nos
centrreeville et le stationnement dans
tout ça vous allez me dire il ne
contribue pas à l'échelle humaine en
plus personne veut avoir une vue sur le
stationnement à partir de sa terrasse ou
de son balcon alors il est plus
avantageux de les rendre invisible en le
localisant en arrière ou même en
souterrain ça c'est une solution qui se
fait de plus en plus au Québec mais il
peut aussi être intégré discrètement
comme dans cet exemple à stutgard où ils
sont décidés de concentrer les
stationnements et les accès aux maisons
individuelles se font par des salé
piétons tout les réidents on une belle
vue et un environnement très agréable un
milieu de vie à échelle humaine est
aussi un milieu compact et pour cela je
ne veux pas dire
dansse un milieu compact va réduire les
distances entre les activités par sa
forme urbaine comme l'école l'épicerie
l'espace des jou où l'on on pe où on
peut alors se rendre à pied un milieu de
vie de qualité est aussi un milieu
sécuritaire quelque chose qu'on cherche
toujours à voir dans nos quartiers par
erreur on privilégie la faible densité
par rapport au quartiers plus dense
parce que que l'on considère que c'est
moins sécuritaire
or la sécurité dépend davantage de la
train et des aménagements des rues de la
qualité des espace public mais surtout
de l'animation et la présence
humaine par exemple une rue étroite va
obliger les les véhicules à ralentir
seul les résidents résidents vont
l'utiliser et les enfants vont pouvoir
jouer sans aucun risque un milieu de vie
sécuritaire accorde place de qualité au
piéton et
cycliste la présence des végétations
contribue à marquer le caractère de la
rue et à le rendre plus
sécurissant les rues partagées les
ruelles et cheminement piéton offrent
des raccourcis piétons sans sans pour
autant favoriser les transites
automobiles ell peuent alors devenir une
extension de la
cour en milieu de vie des qualité va
offrir un confort à ces
résidents par la qualité de la
conception et de la construction de ces
bâtiments et de ces espaces
verts c'est le travail de la ville
d'imposer aux promoteurs et aux
entrepreneurs un niveau
d'efficaciténerg d'efficacité
énergétique et d'insonorisation dans nos
bâtiments pour les habitats collectives
la présence des des grands balcons et
des terrasses tous les deux bien
orientés va compenser l'absence de la
cour privée surtout s'ils sont
utilisables toute
l'année au Québec on aime beaucoup les
piscines parce que on a un hiver de 6
mois mais plutôt que chacun chacun aille
sa piscine et les des Jux d'enfant
individuels on pourrait viser faire des
CS privé un petit peu moins grains pour
priviléger des coûts partagés aménagés
au goût des propriétaires un partage des
coûts et de l'entretien de une piscine
et des jeux communs qui vont favoriser
la vie du
quartier aussi un milieu de vie des
qualités est synonyme d'un milieu
diversifié qui répond à la demand un
logement pour tous les résidents ou
offre pour tous les sages et pour tous
les
goûts et on a tendance à créer des
quartti
exclusivement résidentiel
unifamilial parce que on ne veut pas
discuter une possible diversité on veut
tous des maisons individuelles n'est-ce
pas comme le fait nos
parents la maison individuelle n'est pas
une fin en soi oui effectivement les
milieux de vie de qualité vont toujours
avoir la maison individuelle ou en
ranger mais aussi ils vont avoir des
jouelés qui ne sont pas vu comme une
solution de transition mais plutôt comme
une maison adaptée au mode de vie des
familles d'aujourd'hui sans dé laisser
les modèles de petite taille on pourrait
offrir des jumelés de plus grandes
dimensions un milieu diversifié va aussi
avoir des condos on constate que notre
population est vieillissante et qu' on a
de plus en plus des jeunes familles des
ménages pour lesquels ces produits
deviennent de plus en plus intéressants
et il faut pas oublier les bâtiments
collectives qui vont offrir des espaces
verts de qualité comme l'équivalent
d'une 4è
chambre si ça c'est une formule que
j'aime beaucoup personnellement c'est
des condos au étag pour personnes âgées
et une garderie au reedchaussé une
combination ù grandparents et enfant
vont profiter l'un de l'autre d'une
façon
extraordinaire
contrairement à cet exemple ici un
milieu de vie de qualité va privilégier
autant de proet Nève en propriété en
location en copropriété et en logement
social des quartiers mixtes où 10 à 20 %
des logements sont destinés au logement
social et un autre pourcentage au à la
copropriété
excusez toutes ceci sans oublier
l'importance d' une qualité
architecturale et non une architecture
en
série il faudrait viser alors des
quartiers où chaque maison c'est une
découverte des matériaux des formes des
styles et non des
quartiers composés par des blocs
monotones une architecture riche qui
rend nos déplacements quotidien un
moment plaisant et
agréable un milieu de vie de qualité est
aussi un milieu dont les possibilités de
socialiser son sont
infinis par exemple une place publique
c'est un lieu privilégié des
rassemblements des places publiques qui
peuvent devenir des marchés publics qui
vont aider à promouvoir la production
locale mais pour provoquer des
rencontres et des activités sociales il
faut réfléchir à la localisation la
qualité des espaces et à la variété des
commerces ajoutant des équipements un
public des loisir bien localisés qui
vont apporter nécessairement une plusvue
à notre quartier et plein d'opportunités
de
socialiser finalement un milieu de vie
de qualité est aussi en lien avec la
nature en essayant de s'en rapprocher on
finit par s'éloigner et créer le
l'talement urbain depuis que j'habite en
région je constate que que les nouveaux
quartiers se ressemble à tout autre
quartier au Québec et cela ce n'est pas
un compliment on est en campagne et on
NTI pas autant d'avantages qu'on les
devrait on fait d's à notre plus grande
qualité alors qu'on devrait laisser
rentrer la nature dans nos
quartiers ici en exemple allemand où on
a su bien inérer la nature au quartier
et améliorer la qualité de ces réidents
je vous laisse en vous disant que c'est
le rôle de la ville des promoteurs des
entrepreneurs des professionnels et de
tous nous nos comme
citoyens faire de notre ville une ville
de façon plus humaine rappelons-nous que
nos villes sont notre histoire les
reflets d'une société nous en région on
est fier de notre nos région et de notre
communauté alors quelle ville on veut
continuer à construire celle qui
va reproduire les erreurs des autres ou
une petite ville modèle que tout le
monde cite un
exemple
[Applaudissements]
merci